hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my readers in the forum
Savannah who posted about a new website
that I guess she's working for called
Northwest Fresh clothing and wanted some
advice tips or feedback so here's the
website and I don't see where savannah
is but it's talking about Mitch Larsen
so hey my name is Mitchell RCM 16 years
old always one at my own clothing line
this out came up with the company so
first off it's a simple design but
that's fine you're just getting set it
out I like that you have a personal
introduction from yourself often with
these types of small companies it's
great to have that personal connection
that you can try to build so people get
to know your store and they want to know
a little bit more about you and then
they get attached to it and they want to
buy your product I definitely put my
face here so I'm assuming this is you
whatever you you know mention your name
and you're making a warm introduction
I'd put my face so people can see you
and hopefully you know you've got a nice
smile and people can look into your eyes
and want to learn a little bit more
about you so I definitely put my face
their turn that picture around you going
to say keeping my price as low as my
number one priority for these designer
types of clothes pricing is not the
issue you know people want to buy your
product because they love the designer
they like the brand they like who you're
associated with so pricing I wouldn't
worry about I to more focus on what your
design is about so you know you're
talking about your signature designs
your goals to get your word out but what
is your brand same for and who's wearing
it and what cuts of products you making
that's how I would focus on here in this
intro is they're talking about how you
want to keep your prices lobe and then
what I guess scrolling down it's a
pretty pretty simple page you're trying
to get people onto your your Facebook
page that's fine i would probably remove
this
ad for godaddy here at the bottom my
toes even remove the counter if that's
not really going up if it's not that big
a number you know you don't want to have
those types of things on there if we
look over here if you look at what
you're selling so you're selling
different t-shirts you know if this is
you then I put one of these pictures up
here you got a good smile people can
kind of get to know you a little bit
better so that should be your one of
these should be your home page picture
instead of what you have up there people
can buy is fine what else can we load up
here guestbook bad you got some comments
bull riding you might want to respond
here just so that this shows that
there's community but its ongoing you
have some in january december the danger
with these types of things is it gets
stale so if nobody's written for a long
time then it looks like you know your
brain doesn't exist but you have some
comments up here which is great and that
might get indexed as well and then I
guess it's just likes to your Facebook
page or this is your Twitter account so
not bad I would definitely focus on
maybe improving the design a little bit
more you can go to a site like 99designs
and how people bid on you know creating
a nice new fresh design for you I try to
talk a little bit more about what your
design stands for where you came up with
these things and what it means you know
I may not be your target market so I
don't necessarily saying what hood
mentality as a t-shirt would mean or you
know the letters that might make sense
to some people but again the more you
can describe it the more that might help
you with your sales so hopefully that
helps if you guys liked the video please
give it a thumbs up below and if you
have some thoughts or suggestions for
how this website could be better feel
free to leave in the comments underneath
and stay tuned for next episode
you